I don't have such to read catbacks when
I got all the facts remaining yeah today
we're gonna learn some cat facts while
playing with kids
okay you not love this look at that look
at that I love cats
good Beth I'm gonna beat some cat back
the to jump to Rizzo Anna slow blinking
by cats as a sign of trust and affection
slow blinking at your cat is received
mutually you can try it let's love look
at these cats slow blinking here look at
me no matter dis lovely she's just like
looking at me being like why is this
crazy man just like blinking at me don't
worry I don't like it when people think
me of it most cats are lactose
intolerant and milk can upset their
stomachs I am calling BS castle milk
that's a stereotype Connick I don't know
well I like your movies of TV they
always show cats turn out like saucers
of milk because if you've ever given a
cat milk he does it's not a cool thing
to believe god that's really good to
know because my mom likes to give my cat
milk we used to put a little whipped
cream in our hand and let our cat look
at you loved it it's okay we won't feed
you new oh my god a group of cats is
called a clowder a clowder
look at this cloud of little cuties
stage-five clowder
it's like clam chowder it's much better
than like a murder of crows it's fun or
to say okay according to a 2009
University of Minnesota study owning a
cat can reduce the risk of stroke and
heart attack I really believe it too
that's great the cats could save your
life if you pet a cat and then they like
start purring on you and it just like
takes away all the stress of your day
I'm having the opposite of a stroke
right now
adult cats actually only me out
communicate with humans my cat didn't
used to me out and then I came home one
summer when I was in high school and
started meowing my cat caught on and now
meows constantly I'm confident that my
cat is always yelling at me to give her
more food how do we know that you think
cats in the wild forget they even know
how to me
trying to say human words welcome to the
captain a woman in England cleans on her
cat detected her breast cancer cat
doctors in nursing homes though they go
to the people who are like about to pass
and be the Companions that's like
meeting and maybe he was given a breast
exam and the cat looked up as I go
something feels wrong here mom getting a
breast exam at mammogram the cat rubs
against people to mark its territory Oh
cats love us they like bumped their
heads on it's like actually because it's
just making sure you're not cheating on
it this is like the lemme smell your
dick version of psych-out proves how
smart you guys are if he scripts behind
the Katers little whiskers that's where
their scent glands are they mark your
territory so you were theirs
it feels so good approximately 6.5
million companion animals enter shelters
nation wild every year and about half of
those animals are cats lots of cats need
adopting so if you are in all these cute
little kitties definitely like a cat
near you that needs top it I wish I
could save all the cats look at these
beautiful these beautiful little kittens
are from the ASPCA and if you want to
see if ASPCA has some cats in your area
check it out in the description below
525,600 here
we're all unique construction and
beautiful